er wollte einen menschen verletzen oder
töten um in deutschland zu bleiben das
gibt der pakistaner zu protokoll der am
mittwoch einen 19 jährigen in der
cottbuser traum mit einem küchenmesser
angreifen wollte dies auch getan hat
schwer verletzt hat jetzt spricht das
opfer ralph p der tatort eine
straßenbahn in cottbus ralf p 19 jahre
alt ist gerade auf dem weg in seiner
berufsschule
dort lernt er elektriker es ist sehr
früh am morgen 20 minuten vor sechster
tauchten plötzlich dieser mann auf dem
kopf trägt er zum zeitpunkt einen
schwarzen turban in der hand ein
küchenmesser verarmtes ralph p in den
rücken der junge azubi ein zufallsopfer
bild traf ihn heute im krankenhaus wo
die bauern stehen geblieben ist
vergangen wochen gespürt hab mich
umgedreht maskierten täter gesehen und
versandten sagten zu mir zurück
unfassbar direkt nach seiner tat stieg
er einfach wieder in die bahn
lachend und als wäre nichts passiert der
mann absolut saarland er 28 jahre alt
aus pakistan nach deutschland gekommen
war - matthew ist offenbar groß
verschwunden die bahn stand und da waren
die türen offen
kommst du noch direkt verschwinden
langsam besser
ebenso unfassbar was abdul salam erst
später der polizei zu seinen motiven
erzählt er habe einen menschen verletzen
oder töten wollen um sich einen weiteren
verbleib in deutschland zu sichern
denn seiner aufenthaltserlaubnis in
deutschland sei gerade abgelaufen mehr
nachrichten um breaking news nur bei
bild schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren